all right guys
bang bang kevin is here in person how
long has it been since you've done one
of these in person it's been a while
i mean we're you know miami's kind of
fully open here so here we are
all right where do you live are you
living in miami now i am i live right on
the beach
right on collins avenue i love it i love
the bohemian lifestyle i walked
everywhere i eat dinner every night
i just love the place uh i've seen you
multiple times riding your bicycle we've
gone to dinner you've ridden
the mr wonderful bike there yeah did you
recover it somebody stole it
so it got stolen all right a big
big operation they stole over 100 bikes
that night in vespas
oh so this was not a targeted no crime
well i found out later
um it and i offered a 25 000 reward not
for the bike
you know i wanted to catch the guy that
did it so their
organized crime organization and they
put in a truck and they put the truck on
a barge in the river
and they took maybe 250 bikes that night
off the streets of miami
and what do they do with them they
apparently sell them they take them
offshore
they put it on a ship and just so my mr
wonderful is in some south american
country right now
and viva la the bike company that made
it for me uh saw it on social media and
said let's do another one even crazier
so i was there last week designing the
craziest miami bike you've ever seen
it's pink it's red it's black don't have
it though it's going to
when you see it i'm going to be mr
wonderful ala miami
all right uh i feel like you've done a
great job
shark tank all the social media uh cnbc
etc you built this massive audience
yeah uh how do you think about that
stuff versus like the investing activity
do you still spend a lot of time
investing or is it more so now you've
got the investments you've got you've
made those investments and now it's more
of the the media focus and kind of the
content
i think a new model is emerging and
you're actually part of this new model
and let me explain
the way i see it over the last 24 months
so
um let's take a company that is trading
mindmed when i got approached with that
uh company here in miami at the soho
club second floor
it was a bunch of crypto guys three
years ago one guy there
named j.r rand said look i'm a
kryptonian however
i also have a great interest in
psychedelics as medicine i said you're
crazy
those are illegal drugs lsd is illegal
schedule 1 narcotics same as cannabis
psilocybin all of this stuff he said no
no i'm going to go to the fda
form a company and do clinical trials
there's no recreational use of this
and you know i want 3 million bucks
and i said you know it's too crazy but
i'm gonna my guy alex
um who does runs all their adventures
he's got a team we'll do due diligence
on it it's intriguing enough
that was three years ago alex worked on
it for about two months
and he really went to town on it and did
a lot of research with his guys
and the way my deal with alex works to
give you an idea
of how this works so i probably told you
i already know but go ahead okay so
when we do an investment you know i'm
the bank i lend him 15
so his you know what's are on the line
he borrows the money for me and he
invests beside me he gets his own stock
but he owes me the dough
15 so that i know our interests are
aligned
this is the first time in history on
mine mid where he came back to me and
said i'm taking your 15
and i'm tripling it with my own dough
and i went what
why and he laid out his case we ended up
investing that went from a 20 million
20 million valuation that we bought in
at to now 1.7 billion so it's my biggest
winner in years but those are the kind
of investments and how did that story
happen
this is where social media intersected
with the story of mind mid
it got into the rolling stone it was in
you know all the news magazines it was
in the popular press it was all over
social media
because i was talking about along with
all the other advocates and the story
built into a giant company that has over
300 000 shareholders so my new model
pomp is this
you want me to get involved in your
business all right i want a proprietary
position i don't care what your last
round was at i want to be a founder so
you're going to give up the stock
but then i'm going to turn on my machine
and if you have a if you have a story of
merit
i will explain it to other shareholders
and hopefully we'll build this business
together
using all the tools the new world has
shows like this
social media yahoo finance benzingo cnbc
cnn abc that's how companies get to be
known
not just for shareholders to tell their
product story
why should you care about microdosing
lsd because it works or at least it
potentially can
and it's going through clinical trials
and it can solve for
you know addiction opiate addiction
anxiety
alcoholism all these things is there a
specific type of company that this works
for
more so than other types of companies
like does it have to have some inherent
story behind it and some interest
and that's really what you're trying to
underwrite just as much as the actual
investment itself
it's a great question but the truth is
every company has to be able to tell
their story in the best light i don't
care if it's really sophisticated
technology
i mean it's much better when it's
consumer good or service but
right now the reason crypto is of such
interest globally is the story was told
by guys like you for years
and it slowly emerged as a story of you
know store of wealth if you want to call
it that or currency if you want to call
it that whatever it was
it's the fact that investing has become
democratized by the robin hoods by the
reddit crowd by all the
news channels buy the cable channels
business is part of
everyday news every day and so if you
can get a following that is interested
in your investment philosophy i invest
sustainably ethically that's what i do
that's where i came from that's
all i do and people that are interested
in that follow
they don't have to invest with me they
don't have to they can bet against me
but at least they hear these companies
stories so my argument is
that the value i have to a company now
is
the ability to take its story and blow
it up
and then investors will make their own
individual decisions but that's
very hard to get to that place and it's
taken me a long time as it has taken you
and i want to use that power wisely when
you think about public markets versus
private markets
how much of this is uh better suited for
public markets where there's
liquid stock price there are
shareholders people can make decisions
every day buy sell hold whatever
versus the private market where um
there's not so much
access for some investors right there's
not that liquid kind of daily stock
price
uh and maybe the impact is more around
like helping the business built
in terms of getting customers or driving
you know consumers to check it out or
whatever
is it either or or can this work across
both public and private markets
it's both and the most powerful platform
to tie these together
is equity you know crowdfunding now
where you can tell a consumer of a
product or service that you can become a
shareholder at the same time i'm very
intrigued by that i have a relationship
with start engine now
one of the largest crowdfunding
platforms in the world so when a company
has
a hundred thousand customers that have
tried its product it's still private
we can go to the customers and say look
you love our product you love our
service now we're going public you can
buy our shares
you can buy them online you can put 200
or 2 000 or 20 000
into the company that you've been
supporting now for five years and that's
this is again another digital you know
crossroads
of equity and funding and debt to the
consumer
which doesn't have the same issue around
timing like a private equity firm does
or a venture capital firm where after
seven years they turn into a pumpkin
and they want to prep share and they
want this and they want all these
special rights
i'm not into that anymore i'd rather do
you want to raise 50 million let's do it
in equity crowdfunding where everybody
owns the same share all the interests
are aligned there's no time bomb
people can buy and sell their stock
anytime they want and so for me
it again goes to the platform what i try
and do with my companies that are
private is get them customer acquisition
costs get theirs down
and i use my platforms to talk about
their products and services i
try to get people to try the products
but you know at the end of the day
um i feel a responsibility i don't
endorse products i don't use personally
i think that's [ __ ]
and i think people can smell [ __ ] a
mile away so i never do that
you know i do things that i use i like
or i invest in and i tell my story and
you can either agree or disagree
but at least i get that mega bullhorn to
get out there and talk about it
yeah um when you think about your career
building up the media side there's a lot
of people who listen who they're very
interested in this and more so founders
are interested in this as well so
one of the big secrets in venture
capital right now is
almost on a daily basis i have a founder
that comes to me and says how do i build
my twitter following how do i build
facebook how do i build instagram you
know
should i create an email newsletter like
what should i do so that i have the same
power maybe it's at a smaller scale but
i can talk directly to an audience
uh that's in my vertical or in my
industry and i think that there's a lot
of
um kind of value that can accrue there
what are the things that you did that
you're like these were the big
inflection points right obviously shark
tank probably was a big one but are
there other things that you're like
this is how i built this massive
platform and kind of made a name for
yourself
where people were willing to at least
listen and hear you out
what i found worked as these you know
it's a it's a complex question because i
get the same question all the time how
can i get
a million followers well it's not that
easy i mean there's people that try and
sell you services to do it there's all
kinds of consultants to try and do it
for you
they want you to pay them 15 grand a
month all that stuff happens but the
truth is
that social media is is the great um
democratizer of people that are good
storytellers
because if you have interesting
information that may assist somebody
or they may find interesting they will
tell another
about it they will send that link to
somebody else and that actually
that organic growth occurred pretty
quickly for me it started you know fifty
thousand hundred thousand two hundred
thousand
then a million and then another million
it and i never
changed i mean i like to have fun on
social media
you know i have i'll play guitar with my
pajamas on on saturday i'm happy to do
that
um people play guitar i like to do that
you know just share it
i talk about stocks i talk about bonds i
get very very serious about issues
around politics
i just lay it out there and it's all
true and i don't [ __ ]
and i think that's what worked for me
but i'm very happy to be in different
verticals
you know i can talk about watches with
anybody in the world now i have a
massive watch collection
i used to be a shareholder and fender i
can play guitar um
i have chef wonderful as a multi-million
dollar business now my wine
business is now the largest direct
consumer in the country really
yeah yeah we just did 5.1 million in 20
hours on qvc last week that's an
all-time record
so these are different verticals that
interest me and there's different
constituents that
come into your universe around those
interests i got a huge following of
people that like wine
tell me more about the wine business i
don't know anything about this yeah so
you know
here's something interesting that i
learned i i grew up uh with a
swiss stepfather who's really taught me
in my teenage years how to uh you know
the difference between bordeaux and
burgundy and drc and the italian wines
and all the varietals and and i
became interested and over in europe you
know wine is just part of family
it's not about getting drunk over there
they just drink it you know maybe one
glass or two glasses it's not a big deal
so kids drink it watered down whatever
and so i became pretty proficient at the
different varietals
i always was interested in why you know
i'm a collector of wine and an investor
i buy one futures with a group in boston
we invest millions of dollars in wine
and we try and guess which varietals
like this year is going to be terrible
because it snowed just last week
in in france it actually snowed it's
it's unprecedented
and the point is when you get
knowledgeable about it you get it's kind
of sucked into that lifestyle
so i started a wine business in
california where i blended it and i sold
it
and i was losing money like everybody
else like a lot of money
everybody goes into it romantically and
i'll joke if you want to be a
millionaire start as a billionaire in
the wine business
because you lose a ton of money and then
i met this woman
through shark tank named annette alvarez
she was the wine buyer for costco the
largest buyer of wine in the
world is costco people don't understand
that all the global wines they are the
largest
seller of wines as well and she said
kevin um
i was trying to sell her a shark tank
deal of single served wines
nobody could ever reach her she was
impossible to get to and i asked one of
the guys in my office to go to the dark
web and hack her cell number
which i had in 10 minutes and i called
it and i left a message
and i said listen i'm the guy on shark
tank
if you're a shark tank fan i don't know
you saw that deal last night
a single serve wine deal cuban and i
went into and i'd love you to costco
to uh this is the cupola wine or
whatever it was it was the yeah and
there was another one called zips as
well
and so i left the um the message and i
thought well maybe she'll call me back
ten minutes later i was up at our lake
house the phone rang and said this is
annette alvarez
i got your message you were rude to
barbara last night
on shark tank i went what what
she said no you're really rude to her
and i said i got to tell you something
annette um the only reason barbara gets
the shark tank on time is i buy her new
broom every year
and she didn't think that was a funny
joke but you're over two with yeah i
know i thought she'd like that but she
didn't and
and anyways we got into a conversation
she said i'm on my way to hawaii for our
annual holiday with my husband
i'll be at john wayne airport at one
o'clock on saturday
it was thursday night and uh if you want
to fly here to
meet me you can bring your wife because
i want to meet your wife too
i said why she said i just do and i want
to see a real person and i said linda
we're going to uh john wayne and we flew
there i got an hour of her time and she
told me this she said look
you want to sell wine with me i'm the
largest buyer on earth
the only reason you get this hour with
me is i'm a huge shark tank fan i have
some questions about the show i'd like
to meet you it's great
but here's what you need to know about
the wine business 97
of wine sold in america is sold for
under 14
a bottle 97
people don't understand that that's all
of the wine pump that's basically
the stuff you buy for 60 bucks you're in
the three percent
in order for you to make money you're
gonna have to be able to ship me a
hundred and fifty thousand cases a day
if i order a cab from you i need a
hundred fifty thousand cases that's just
my stocking order the next day i meet
another hundred thousand
you can't do that you don't have the
capability you don't have the logistics
you can't even understand how much juice
that is
if you want to pull that off i'm going
to give you the name of a guy named pat
roney
he owns 19 vineyards and he makes our
kirkland wine he
is our logistics guy he can ship me 2
million cases
you form a wine company with him you go
50 50 partnership then i know you have
the logistic skills then
then i'll give you an order and it'll
blow your socks off how much wine we can
buy from you
i go to see pat and pat says
i know you're coming and that called me
we're interested let's format a
relationship
we fought for six months on the terms of
it it ended up being 50 50.
it has been wildly successful because
she was right the minute we dropped our
price point
between 11 and 14 we started selling you
know hundreds of thousands of cases
and last week i broke a record never
been done before on qvc we sold
5.125 million dollars worth of wine in
21 hours
that means we have to ship a quarter of
a million cases in two days we can do it
but that's a business that's very
profitable now in fact a spac
took over um that company i'm now a
shareholder in
vintage wine states and it's going to
trade on the nasdaq june 6th
wow and so you also do direct to
consumer as well or it's just
absolutely launching a new site i'll be
announced next week so i'm a little
early on it here called shop mr
wonderful and it's going to have not
only
all my wines but all my shark tank
products so a massive play direct to
consumer as a result of the pandemic
organized by a great digital team a lot
of work going into this
it's it's like extending the voice pomp
as we talked about the beginning of the
show
you know what do i do with this voice
these are products i invested in
i use wines i make my wife blends the
whites i do the reds
this is our family stuff try it it's a
very it's it's an honest pitch
if you don't like the wines ship it back
i mean you know you can send it back if
you want but
when it comes to wine i've got your back
nobody makes wine like i do yeah
uh crypto i think when we first met uh
three years ago maybe now yeah uh cnbc
set
i didn't know very much about you other
than how this guy on shark tank yeah uh
i don't think you knew anything about me
and i told you that 50 of my net worth
in bitcoin i thought you were [ __ ]
crazy
and uh well that that's a nice way of
putting it because i think on the
segment what you said was i forbid you
from
i for being i i remember we were on the
set of
squawk boxes and i thought who is this
idiot yes why would he put so much into
one thing
and uh and you didn't realize that
uh i think i was playing a game with you
and you were playing a game with me
because
uh right before the segment started uh
they were at commercial
and we were all talking or whatever and
uh i was just kind of jabbing you a
little bit trying to get you to
to be excited and then you you said to
me right before i said how much
you know do you have in this i said 50
the lights cameras turn on and that was
the first thing you fired across
well i mean those that was then and but
in 2017 i had nibbled in
i'd start buying some bitcoin and some
um
you know ethereum at that time and a
couple of other i think us uh
i can't remember when i bought my stable
coins but you know what happened to me
it because i'm in a highly regulated
industry with you know
all my indexing and all these financial
services companies that i've invested in
so i'm really regulated by the
regulators and i started talking about
crypto and
whoa what a negative response back then
you remember
it was it was especially 2018 when it
had dropped from 20 000 bitcoin price to
3 200. so i got my wings clip pretty
pretty hard by lawyers in washington
saying you got to stop
i mean you know you're a heavily
regulated guy and you're out there on tv
talking about bitcoin forget it
and you talk about as much as you want
or not but like
i think a lot of people think uh elon
tweets something or there's somebody who
is really bullish who all of a sudden is
a little bit more bearish and
they call the tap on the shoulder right
the like hey knock it off type thing
yeah is that like a you know goes
through the back
door conversations someone just says hey
you know you should chill with that
or is that like something that is uh
kind of more
uh stated right in terms of the way it
works is
i i i have to be compliant as per the
compliance officers that work in these
companies
every single word i say including this
this podcast is going to be reviewed by
compliance
and these are organizations i have to be
compliant with because
they have to be they're telling the
regulators that we are compliant and
they have to make sure that's their job
and so i i started getting calls from
lots of them in different companies
saying you're way offside
and you've got to stop and i did and i
you know um what happened though
if only it was only eight months ago
when the swiss regulator the french
regulator the german
uh new zealand brent britain switzerland
and canada they started putting etfs out
the regulators had gone 360 or 180
whatever you call it right
and i said well wait a second i'm an
investor in those jurisdictions i have
investments in all those jurisdictions
i'm a global investor i have them
investments in all those currencies i am
going to buy some
um bitcoin as i can in
in those jurisdictions we don't have it
here yet the same way but it's coming i
would assume
and obviously the regulators have lifted
their their curtain or
made it easier to do that and so i
started um
growing my position to three percent
i'm a five in the operating company so
we have five percent in gold for example
i said let's go crypto uh to three
and we started buying coins and we
started buying ether and we started you
know investing in a few other things
and then i started getting calls and i
think i've talked to you about this
i service uh institutional clients and
sovereign funds and they they saw me on
cnbc talking about my three percent
waiting
and the phone lit up it went nuts
and what was it about it was about esg
it was about this issue around
sustainability
and saying where'd your coin come from
but they were mine in china i said well
who cares it's all fungible coins
bitcoin's a bitcoin it's awarded it's a
coin they said well we're you're
supporting cold buy
coal burning uh miners you know
this issue i predicted would explode and
i think i've been right on that thing
but it hasn't changed my interest
in uh going long bitcoin for a bunch of
reasons because i've gotten a lot more
sophisticated now
what interests me the most right now is
defy i think it's where the puck is
going i'll tell you why
so now i've got a large amount of
capital tied up three percent waiting in
the operating companies a lot of capital
and it's not yielding anything right so
why don't
so i said to my guys let's get into some
d5 and take a portion of the assets
and wrap it into the ethereum chain and
let's start making some interest
let's start looking at different ways
that we can loan our our assets out
and start making four five six seven
eight you know i've talked about this
i have gotten way down that rabbit hole
and and i'm
way deep into that now what's up guys
bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
block five block five's got four
different financial products for crypto
investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
again blockfy.com pomp go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it so
uh let's stop for a second just so
people understand where we are so you
got three percent
of operating company assets right in
crypto you've got five percent in gold
uh first question
is why still five percent gold three
percent crypto
uh i think a lot of people who've kind
of gone down the rabbit hole of crypto
either invert that right so it's five
percent crypto three gold or like
literally have gotten rid of the gold
so why still have more gold than crypto
right now you know that
it's a great question and we've had that
discussion internally every we do our
our meetings uh every monday at 10
o'clock we review the portfolio changes
et cetera
i know there's going to be a change
there soon because it comes up every
monday now okay
because we can't make any interest off
gold and we now are starting to get
yield
and starting to make money and the weird
thing as you well know
we've had tremendous volatility in
bitcoin this last 10 days
that actually enhances d5 it makes it
better i'm making way more on my
contracts now
and so you know i said to the guys look
um and this is you know brad this is i
haven't even told anybody this story
it's just unique it's on your podcast
because it's so new
um you only bring me the good stories
well you know we talk about a lot of
stuff so
i said to the guys on the on my crypto
team
look this d5 stuff is really complicated
it is not easy you know we've got a
metamask format we've got all of these
other platforms all the stuff we have to
do these contracts
this is crazy complicated but there must
be millions of people that have a little
bit of coin that want to make some four
or five six percent on it
why don't you go find me a company
a team that i can invest in that will do
a commercialized d5 and i mean not
not corporate so that somebody that has
a wallet that's got maybe you know 20
grand or 10 or 5 000
in it could easily do what i'm doing
that takes a staff of four people
you're basically talking about more
user-friendly better user experience an
easy way hey i elect i want to do
this and rather than me actually have to
go in and do it myself
i can use this service to accomplish
this yeah and so
they came up with this team again it's
in a different jurisdiction because it's
canada which is very open these days
a vancouver team that one of my crypto
guys uh introduced me to
ben is the uh you know and he's got a
great
almost 20 people there doing this that
they're all ex-bankers they understand
the whole format they're
they're deep deep deep into the
algorithms and all the code they're
writing
and they said look we're looking to
raise some money here um
uh do you want to be an investor and i
said yeah i'll take this on
i'll i'll uh but i want to buy a third
of the company i want to be a
significant shareholder
and we negotiated for a while because
you're going to be you're going to do
two things for me
i'm going to help your company but i'm
going to give you a ton of capital and
you're going to manage it
according to the way i want to manage it
and you're going to produce things that
i want because i know if i want them
others are going to want them like tax
returns
i want to press a button get a tax
return i don't i want to be compliant
right
nobody does that yet i don't want to
have to sit there with an account and
figure out all my trades i want to
automatically produce
he's working on that his team is working
on that so we put
we put a significant round together for
them a 20 million dollar round
um i'm the lead on that thing and uh
uh i think it's going to be a great
company we haven't even announced it yet
it's
it's called d5 ventures um i'm going to
rename it to wonderfuy
because it's it's going to be my my
vehicle
and um i think it's just the beginning
you know some great things to come
and uh so when you go into d5 what
exactly are you guys doing you're taking
bitcoin that you own and ether and ernie
so there must be many other investors
like me i've made my decision to three
to five percent allocation
probably as you as you've snuck out of
me i'm gonna be moving it up because
you're right gold's not doing anything
for me
well three plus five is eight not five
so you could get rid of all that gold
could get to ten
okay all right but you know we're bound
by certain covenants just
how we manage the operating company ten
i feel like is on the upper bound of
most conservative investors right so it
still fits within the
kind of bands if you will if you're a
conservative investor most of your focus
is outside of crypto
yeah one to ten percent is kind of the
ban is up there
five percent institutional investor 10
is up there of course right now that
number
for the big guys is three percent
they're happy and they they want
bitcoin they haven't gotten past that
yet
bitcoin is the property the digital
asset they want
um and they want to store value store
value and you've been right on that
can't deny that okay
it's a it's a volleyball we might have
to roll the tape back and they have to
erase that
but my whole point is the the it it has
inherent volatility but imagine
so here's my thoughts about d5 okay i've
got the vol i know i'm going to be up
up and down 38 a year that's what it's
been historically right
so we're seeing that we've had a crazy
vault right here we're literally
recording this on a day that uh
it's been down 40 in a month okay so so
let's say in in my case my defy company
of which i'm a large shareholder now
i say to the guys look let's put a bunch
of crypto on our balance sheet
all right i'm going to own a third of
that balance sheet or whatever i own of
the balance sheet
i want you to loan that out and get me
between a four and a half and an eight
percent yield
now of course i have to mark to market
the change in value
because it's going up and down but i'm
kind of agnostic because i'm owning it
as property i don't
really care because it's an allocation
let's say it's five percent
it's going to stay at five i'll change
it every quarter adding and taking away
from it
but i want you to loan it out there so
the whole
operation the defy operation is to start
doing these contracts for me on an ai
basis
so it can go look to the market see what
the spreads are on all these different
opportunities i don't want to get too
complicated
basically yield for me what you're going
to do for me and then
others that are interested like i am on
taking their asset
and imagine if i could have over these
years had a five percent yield on my
gold
that would have been incredible well i
can on my crypto so
that's really what i'm doing in d5 and i
think i've got the best team in north
america everybody says that but
i'm backing this team because i've done
a lot of due diligence on them
and i think you know in the next few
months
that will become part of our portfolio
with a yield metric to it
so because what you're basically saying
is uh you're going to keep the assets
denominated in the asset right so
uh let's say just for easy things you
have uh a hundred
eth you put that in you want eight
percent so now you're going to end the
year with a hundred and eight eight
staying in regardless of did the price
go up or down i might go back to fiat to
just pay some expenses
but i'm going to stay in eath on that
balance sheet and you as a shareholder
go with me in the share price as my
assets grow
do you think that this is a really
important piece that i think the
traditional world hasn't woken up to yet
sounds like you're now getting there
is um once you leave fiat into
crypto yeah you don't go back i don't
want to go back okay why would i
well i don't know you tell me how do you
think about it right so you've got
100 of your assets you've said i'm gonna
take three i'm gonna put it into crypto
yeah
uh maybe that goes up maybe it doesn't
whatever but let's just say it's three
to five percent whatever the allocation
is
once you put that into crypto why are
you not going back well the reason i
would come back out let's say
let's say our covenant is a max on 10
which is most institutions that is max
arena okay all right so 10 is the max
allocation
because because if you're going you know
you basically if you have lps or you
have
other shareholders or you have other
constituents you've told them you have a
covenant of diversification and it might
be 10
whatever it is but it's not much higher
than that so when you get to 12
the end of a quarter in your crypto
you're going to trim back to fiat
you're going to go back to 10 percent or
or maybe you know
um and then you just sit in the weeds
waiting for correction and you buy back
up to 10
i've you know i've been buying like i
mean you bought the dip
well it's it's it's not really a dip
it's maintaining the three percent
weighting right
yeah no but i'm saying the dip in the
price i know i know but it but to me
it's okay
we're 2.4 and we said we're a three buy
up to three because we've had a
correction you can't call that that's a
correction
well i mean look in 2017 there's what
six over thirty percent i think right
there was two forty percent draw down so
uh it doesn't feel good right well i
don't know when the asset
draws down but it's not uh atypical for
the kind of historical bull runs right
right which
again if you tell in the traditional
world uh hey there's gonna be two forty
percent drawdowns but you're gonna go up
20 x in a year
they're like i'm out well yeah i'm out
of this
but but in this case um you end up with
more coin after that correction and then
you're out loaning it out and you're
getting your
and with that volatility you just got
200 basis points more yield people don't
understand
vol is good for yield it's not good for
your stomach
but it actually helps you mine yield
from your crypto
and so when you understand those smart
contracts and how it's being loaned out
um and i'm getting way more
sophisticated so i look at it now
with my team saying okay you know you
could even put leverage on this if you
want which we don't
but i think that's a crazy chicken move
but you could really goose your hair
why are you only targeting four and a
half to eight percent some of these can
pay
twenty percent thirty percent what's
your duration what duration well that's
why i'm asking you right
is it just you're saying hey i want to
be able to earn the four and a half to
eight percent forever
and the 20 to 30 is only there for a
couple of weeks or a couple of months
like
how do you think about yield verse
duration so what we don't have is a long
history of what that curve on duration
looks like
you just don't have it we're all
pioneers in this and because i'm a bond
guy i've been a bond guy for decades and
so what i look at is duration and
quality
you don't you can't work with that yet
we don't know so i said look let's keep
our contract short let's understand
the change in the deltas let's
understand you know how inefficient the
market is when there's a lot of
volatility let's just
gather our own data keep our powder dry
let's only loan out 50 of our positions
until we understand it works
and i should also disclose i'm working
with some of the larger
corporate defy guys i've opened accounts
to manage some of my company's balance
sheets i'm putting up to five percent of
our
fiat currency into a strategy like this
on our balance sheets
i don't talk about that too much but i'm
letting you know i'm saying guys
we're in let's have an operating company
it's sitting with you know
30 million dollars in cash let's put
million and a half
into this strategy we'll open an account
you'll understand it works you're the
treasury let me show you how it works
how i'm doing it
let's disclose to uh if they're private
we just have to disclose to our lp's
what we're doing
i haven't anybody said to me no i don't
want that everybody wants to learn
so instead of making nothing on our cash
which we're basically under inflation
we're losing money on our cash you know
we're picking up we're doing better than
four and a half that was a few weeks ago
when coin was very stable
now like today i'm you can get seven
eight nine
as you know so it's not impossible and
so i think
i only put five percent of the company's
assets why not do more if
it's just yield you're not taking the
price risk necessarily in terms of
that's the goal
because the compliance um
departments are all in that let's tiptoe
in
you you know the the concern it's it it
really is a three percent number right
now
there are some at five but here's the
thing that everybody should understand
that
because i live in this world the
potential is
huge you've got less than one percent
of of global corporations even thinking
about crypto right now
so as time passes and they see examples
of what i'm doing and others are doing
and they start to tiptoe in you're
talking about
billions of dollars that are sitting on
balance sheets making nothing and so
it's going to become
that's good and bad news because the
more money goes into that the less yield
you're going to be making there's going
to be a lot of competition
and so but right now i'm tiptoeing
through the tulips you know
almost double-digit yields i think it
comes down commensurate with the
volatility so you here's the thing to
understand i don't want to get too
complicated but let's say when you put a
lot of bitcoin on your balance sheet
you're gonna have vol you're gonna have
volatility the criticism of tesla we've
been watching
they showed on cnbc today all the the
balance sheets that have
you know crypto on it they're all down
because people think oh what was me
they've got crypto it's going to affect
their balance sheet
it does but at the same time they're
loaning it out
if they're smart and they're bringing in
yield that they never used to make on
their cash
so over time when people understand this
it'll offset it
i think people when they hear this
they're gonna be very surprised to hear
that you're buying the dip
you're getting into d5 you're earning
yield right those are uh
various um fairly sophisticated
strategies
compared to just by bitcoin right or uh
hey i want to buy a mining stock for
example
because you're getting more and more in
the weeds right over the last like two
years maybe went from
uh hey i probably shouldn't talk that
much about this to okay maybe there's
something interesting to three percent
now like hey let's start going further
and further into the weeds
where does this go like 10 years from
now like if you just fast forward and
you say okay hold on a second like
there's a bunch of stuff that has to get
built and get there eventually it's just
100 of corporate balance sheets or
you know in digital assets and so
there's digital dollars but also bitcoin
ether whatever
there's yield there's like all like a
true decentralized financial system that
gets built here kind of right out
underneath of wall street
or is there coexistence or like just
like where are we going i guess
i guess what's happening is the money is
looking for the most frictionless way
to actually be productive and so the
reason
d5 is so interesting instead of paying
those crazy 200 bases to 2
fees that these wallets are charging i
don't need those guys for anything
maybe i need a ramp to put my fiat into
ether or whatever
but after that i don't need them and i
can go and do this for a fraction of
those costs on a decentralized basis
what got me into this was we're always
trying to find a place for our cash
like when we haven't found an investment
we want some kind of yield on our cash
and right now we have a lot of cash
because we sold a lot of commercial real
estate during
just before the pandemic and during it
because i'm worried about what happens
to all that
office tower space i'm not sure
everybody's coming back the way they
think
so one of the guys that works with alex
that runs all their adventures was one
of our interns
heavy crypto eric's name i'm not going
to tell you a second name so nobody bugs
them but
he came to me and said listen you got a
ton of cash here
why don't we start a fund a structured
product
that does exactly what we've been
talking about and i said why is it going
to be structured product you said
because
in the jurisdiction we're going to put
the fund where you're going to invest
the cash
they allow this we don't allow it here
in the us yet but there's other
jurisdictions like switzerland and
everywhere else
and you and you just report your gains
to the irs as you said any other asset
and he worked on it uh he went way down
the rabbit hole on it
and um he's still working on it it may
still come to pass but in the meantime
i said to him eric why don't you and
alice go find me a company that's doing
this already
i don't need to have a fund i got the
cash let's just
buy the company and put our cash on the
balance sheet if we're a large enough
shareholder
we won't care and uh is which is what we
did and he
so he found the company he introduced me
uh to these guys in vancouver
you know uh d5 ventures and i met the
ceo and the whole team and i went
wow and i showed other investors the
team and said hey guys do you want to
come in with me
put this deal together and that's that's
actually how it happened and along the
way
uh you know i ran into guys you know
josh richards his partner animal
ventures all those guys
we all looked at it together and said
this is cool so we're partners on it
i think it's great i mean and he you
know he he
josh is like some phenom you know gen
z guy that wants to be part of this and
so i said okay
who's better at picking stocks you were
josh we did it
we did it with wine the other day and he
shouldn't even be drinking
he's only 19. but i met his parents
online he's a great cool kid and and uh
you know griff his partner
and mike michael gruen and all those
guys we have fun together
and uh i actually introduced them to the
crew at cnbc and i said you got to get
this guy on as
the gen z guy like you're the crypto guy
i'm the institutional guy
he should be the gen z guy he's very
smart
i i like him and i said you know you
want to come into a couple of deals with
me let's work together and find some
stuff
and he's been backed by some heavy
hitters you know yeah oh yeah yeah i
i know the whole story um i think part
of uh what's so fascinating is
uh you have a lot of different worlds
that collide right so you've got
wine you've got watches you've got shark
tank you've got uh commercial real
estate you've got your traditional
kind of businesses and investing uh
venture capital and then you've also got
crypto yeah and when all that comes
together is it fair just to say like
you're just looking for the best
opportunities
you would be right but you know i'm like
you
i want to enjoy what i'm doing i want to
get up in the day and say
everything that nancy's plotted for this
day including being here with you i want
to do it i don't want to do stuff
i don't have to do anything but i want
to do stuff
and i love working with entrepreneurs i
just i like finding people and saying
look don't do that because i've
been there before it's a mistake do this
or i can help you here i can help you
here
and let me come along for the ride and
let me bring in shareholders vest beside
me and let's do stuff together
i have a community of entrepreneurs that
enjoy
like you know i work all day and all
night and i love what i do when i get up
and play the guitar in the middle of the
night i
was wailing on the balcony the other day
like two in the morning i know they're
pissed at me on the beach
but it was just fun for a couple of
minutes you just enjoyed it i enjoyed it
and so that that kind of you know it's
it's like uh
live your life because as if there won't
be another tomorrow
and try and make some money because it's
expensive can i ask you a uh somewhat
personal question sure i've never asked
you this before
do you have like a number in mind that
you would eventually say you know what
i've had my fun but like
i am now rich enough where like i want
to walk away is there
a milestone or is it literally
you're gonna die working and you'll just
never
retire you'll never stop i'm not i'm not
working for money anymore i don't need
any more i don't want to lose what i've
got
um and there's always another watch to
buy and so
you know every the the reason i do deals
is
in my world you have to do a deal to buy
a watch so you remember what deal
that watch was from and that's the
collection so i'm always doing deals to
buy watches
that's basically the way i look at it so
i got a you know a massive watch
collection now and that community
is a very interesting global community
i've met some of the biggest collectors
in the world
some of the princes in the middle east
i'm friends with them now because
you know we were on whatsapp talking
about different watches it's a great
community to be
associated with and when we find a rare
piece you know everybody gets excited
about it and
it's just i don't know it's just
interesting i enjoy it
so what is it why are you doing it is it
literally just to get a watch
yeah you know it's a good question you
enjoy it i
i i know you well enough at this point
now i know you enjoy this stuff i do
right
but i'll tell you why i do it i tried
the other
way i took on my first big score the
sale of a learning company is a
4.2 billion dollar transaction including
the debt there were 10 of us as founders
we had all started with in middle class
or you know no money and
and we'd worked together for you know i
don't know 12 years or something
and then that was a massive liquidity
and i remember when we closed we were in
cambridge
and we were sitting around a table just
like this 10 of us you know having lunch
we we ordered in some lunch to talk and
we closed the deal
so now we were funded and and i said to
every
what's everybody going to do i mean like
you know we're
they bought our company they don't need
us what are we going to do
and um how old are you at this point i
think i was uh
30 maybe early 30s
maybe 29. okay all right so around 30.
yeah around 30.
and um i said you know i'm going to take
i'm going to take uh
some time off i'm going to go to every
beach on earth
i just want to go to every beach on
earth including those ones in cambodia
vietnam
thailand you know these incredible
beaches the northern part of cyprus
these
all these legendary beaches and i did it
took me three years
and at the end of it i was bored out of
my [ __ ] mind i mean i just said
this sucks it was depressing this is it
this is all i do is go to beaches and
sit there and get drunk it's just boring
and i got back in the game i mean i just
got i started doing deals like crazy and
i put my capital work i became an
investor not an operator
i i made some great scores i made some
cat you know catastrophic failures
i lost millions i made millions and then
i got in the groove and i figured out
what is it i'm good at
and you know um and then the shark tank
thing came along and that became a huge
platform
um then the cnbc thing came along and it
kind of just morphed into this uh
you know like you know people know
exactly i'm pretty transparent not
everybody likes me they think i tell the
truth too much
about you know business i think it's
good but anyways it is what it is at
this point so i'm kind of
riding the wave looking for
opportunities shark tank got renewed
yes thirteen announced thirteen seasons
i mean you know uh nobody can believe
what happened there
like nobody nobody um
i have another show i taped at telemundo
here in miami which will be announced
this week
i'm excited about it but you know
there's to keep it a secret until
maybe next week i don't know when but
telemundo is a
i'll tell you i've never been to that
studio before it is the most modern
studio
in the world it's completely digital the
whole thing is wired digitally even the
signs are all digital they can change
anything temperature in one part of the
room
it's it and it's massive when jlo
rehearsed
for her super bowl act she did it in a
sound stage there
the size of a football field wow
and i was taping right beside that when
i and i went and looked at it and went
this place has its own
weather zone it's so big the ceilings
were so high
yeah and it's just north of the airport
it's a massive facility
yeah um shark tank
13th season versus the first time you
went on
does it still just as exciting is it
still just as fun
or is it different now well a few things
have changed
um first of all venture capitalists have
now figured out that
they get to 100 million eyeballs for
free so you've got all these vc
back deals like with 50 million
valuations 100 million valuations and my
attitude about that is i don't give a
[ __ ] what your valuation is
if you want me as an investor i'm
carving my own deal and you don't have
to take it
but it's going to be that makes me get a
special position because i add way more
value than your vc does
nobody knows who your venture capitalist
is they don't they don't know the brand
but who cares
they're all the same and they all want
preference shares and all this stuff and
i'm not saying they're bad people i love
venture capitalists but i don't need
them
i can raise my own money for my firms in
my own way
and i don't like preference shares i
don't like shares that are sitting above
me
and have rights i don't have that just
pisses me off so i don't use that stuff
so we get a lot of those companies now
pump we got all these companies that say
if the only we could get on shark tank
right
so we get they have to weed a lot of
those out because they're just gold
diggers
then we get some really interesting
stuff on direct to consumer
like there's a trend emerging in america
let's just take the food
group for example low sodium low sugar
low cal totally healthy like
really eclectic verticals
where people you know that really care
about health will make a different kind
of coffee or a different kind of peanut
butter and what i find what i what i see
happen on those deals is when they hit
the airwaves
you sell five million dollars worth of
it in one hour
yeah a lot of people are into that
health thing so that's a big change
because in the old days we just have
pizza sauce and
you know just hot sauce and sauce and
you know
now it's sauce with no sodium totally
fresh no preservatives all that kind of
stuff
and things like that and and really
they come in knowing what shark they
want they've known us so well now
i want to deal with you know damon and
clothing or you know i want to do a
financial thing with kevin or whatever
it is
and anything in the wedding industry
that's me i love love
uh i want to leave with the best story
from
shark tank that you've ever told me
which is your best investment
which is the potatoes yes tell us the
story and what happened
uh since you did this deal yeah
so it's called potato parcel and
it's a company i'm imagining damon being
here right now and just laughing his
head on he and he did
he did this guy comes on and
he says i take a potato a real potato
and i you send me your image digitally
and i imprint
your face on the potato and then i ship
it
to somebody for you in the u.s meal
and then they put the potato with little
toothpicks
in a little thing of water and the
potato grows right through your face
and it and it takes months to do it and
crazy stuff happens right
i said that's really really stupid i
mean that is
incredibly stupid and what a stupid
business this is
and he said well what is it you care
about in business sales right
and i said of course but nobody would
buy that crap and they said oh yeah look
at this
he had like 30 growth a month
and he was really good at seo he was
really good on on digital really good on
social he was telling the story
and i was sitting there thinking i'm
never gonna invest in this thing so
stupid and i said to him well
how about i get a chunk of equity but i
want a royalty i want to but hold on
you'd already seen
one example of something stupid yeah
make money right that's an important
part
well it's true i saw i want to draw a
cat for you yes which was the stupidest
most stupid thing i've ever seen which
one's dumber potato head or i want to
draw
drug half using incredibly stupid you
pay a guy to draw a cat
and then he mails it to you like and
cuban invested in that made a fortune i
thought that was the stupidest stupid
because he had the song right he like
had that
dance he danced like a cat and it was
like so i thought it's such a piece of
trash what a stupid idea
and it did a ton and and really really
high margins because this guy would just
sit down and draw a cat and he had other
cat drawers
so dumb so when i saw the potato partial
i said there's room in my portfolio for
a
potato
parcel company now remember on shark
tank you calculate
you're putting out capital so you really
want the internal rate of return
on that capital in in really nas
adventure investing
it's return of capital not return on
capital you care about
that thing aired and i got my money back
in like 45 minutes
and so it has the highest return ever
for me and a shark
everything because i had a dollar
royalty on every potato and i own i
can't remember what percentage
i forget what i own the company but that
thing
has has just spun cash and i got calls
from ceos of major corporations saying
listen i want to buy 1500 potatoes for
my sales force globally
and ship them and i want a discount i
say no way there's no discount i'm the
only kid in town
[Laughter]
there's a monopoly on facebook nobody
else puts a face on a potato the way we
can
plus our new gift box pump we get a
premium gift box
with a beautiful little label on it and
a gift package with your face in the
potato
and it comes to your door and you're
just thrilled to death we are pumping
those out by the hundreds of thousands
and there's no discount i mean this is
the elsa primo potato
so there it just shows you with the
right
social media platform what you can do
and and these are real entrepreneurs a
real business it's not a [ __ ]
business
so it's made money it's a watch i'll
tell you that
i'm proud of you because three years ago
when i went on the cnbc
set and you hit me with you were
forbidden you're not at 50
yet yeah but uh you're at three
maybe five maybe well you know you're
headed in the right direction yeah we
are and i think we could eventually get
we may
we may abandon our gold position which
is significant we pay
the way we own gold is we own the gld
for rebalancing even though it's more
expensive it's very liquid
but we also store gold and pay for the
storage so we
it costs us money to hold an asset that
has no yield
and that's the argument that the
committee makes about the gold position
we've got
saying think about this it's reversed
interest if gold stays flat it costs us
to own it
why don't we just allocate 200 basis
points of the gold portfolio just sell
down our glds
go to fiat and then just buy in you know
bitcoin
yeah or you know whatever you can you
don't have to just buy bitcoin but buy a
portfolio of different
crypto you know crypto assets and then
do the contracts
and i'm i'm opening up to it um because
proof is in the pudding and so
it's just and you and the weird thing is
that and you said it earlier
you don't want to go back to fiat and so
you're saying to yourself i'm going to
live with more and more of all
because you are as you build up that
asset but you feel a lot better about
getting
yield off it all of a sudden it's
working for you while you're sleeping as
opposed to
most people think they just own bitcoin
in their wallet pay their ridiculous
fees to their wallet which they don't
have to
i mean people are going to figure this
stuff out they're going to start to see
d5 can be a lot cheaper less
less friction you can still be compliant
i don't want to break any laws
i want to be compliant because i got a
lot of other assets and that's why i
want this version of what we're doing in
vancouver with the uh
you know the d5 ventures guys i want
that to be compliant to the point where
i just press a button to get my tax
return
you know that's how it works yeah i mean
it can so i'm very excited i mean
obviously you've been riding the wave a
lot longer than i have but but i'm
caught up pretty damn fast
you're coming along we just got to get
you to stop uh the other thing you said
one time was a crypto garbage
not garbage garbage which is a little
bit above garbage no but i liked it and
it's now legendary out there and
everybody nails me to the wall on that
thing
they say they say they say you're the
guy that called it garbage
all right ladies and gentlemen my friend
kevin o'leary thank you so much i really
enjoyed it the time flies when i'm
talking with you that's terrific
take care everybody